we also had the pornh house down the
street oh that was amazing we did we did
we had a house at the end of the block
that every other day had the nicest cars
outside and I was like I think they're
like mob or Mafia like that's that was
my that was my middle school thought and
then one day we passed them in a camera
crew went inside and he goes not the
mafia you would see the girls the women
go in in the morning all made up looking
good makeup on later in the day when you
saw it they'd leave with like a
[Applause]
limp
they're their makeup was up they were
just
yeah yeah it was a walk of pain not
shame
yeah yeah so how often did you visit the
house look I never visited but I
definitely walked very slowly past it